margot robbie is pretty in pink
with me
[Music]
yeah margot totally looks like a doll in
this new pic from the set of the live
action barbie movie the actress is
rocking a hot pink ensemble head to toe
complete with bell bottoms that have
stars on them of course so this is
pretty amazing margo's hair long and
blonde with a middle part and waves the
oscar nominees even got herself an iced
coffee to power through because let's be
real being barbie isn't easy oh i'm
having so much fun well bobby we're just
getting started but this isn't the first
time we're seeing margot as the iconic
doll i know i'm excited too in april
warner brothers the studio behind the
flick shared this pic of her rocking a
blue outfit in you guessed it a pink
convertible
hi bobby hi
you want to go for a ride
[Music]
and when e.t spoke with the actress last
year she was coy about the movie but
told us to buckle up expect the
unexpected it's not going to be whatever
you're thinking it's not it's not that
and it wouldn't be a proper barbie movie
without her ken
hey girl
yep ryan gosling is playing ken barbie's
boyfriend something so fun we were
blessed with this ab-tastic photo last
week ryan totally transformed head to
toe
i mean so many abs we've lost count his
look complemented by what else blonde
hair and a tan
as far as how ryan got in shape well his
barbie co-star simulio shared a little
insight he's definitely like a gym in
the morning gym after work kind of guy
and i just um you know as much as i i
believe that i do have a work ethic i
also
love
food
a lot
and you know just hearing little bits
and pieces about you know just his his
strict diet regimen and just like how
you know much emphasis he puts on taking
care of himself and his body i'm like i
i respect it i respect it i'm gonna have
some soda simu who will play another
version of ken took a page out of
margo's book keeping it coy but getting
us ready to party with barbie i feel
like the less i tell you the better
because i feel like every little piece
of news that comes out to tease people
everyone just gets progressively more
confused and curious as to what this
movie is and i kind of like that i feel
like
i feel like july of next year when it
comes people are going to be really
really surprised um just fun just fun
colors like we're wearing bright vibrant
fun celebration
yeah
[Music]